COMPARISON.
>> ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ IS
NOT JUST IN A FEUD WITH ANYONE
WHO THINKS AMERICA SHOULD HAVE A
BORDER.
SHE IS ALSO IN A SPAT WITH THE
FOUNDER OF BAR STOOL SPORTS.
DAVE MADE A SERIES OF ANTI-UNION
TWEETS.
HE SAID HE WOULD FIRE ANY MEMBER
OF HIS STAFF WHO CONTACTED A
PRO-UNION JOURNALIST AND
ACCUSED HIM OF BREAKING THE LAW.
DOESN'T CARE WHEN 20 MILLION
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS BREAK THE LAW
BREAKING INTO THE COUNTRY.
BUT TO USE IT TO SHUT DOWN A
FUNCTIONS BUSINESS, INFRACTIONS
OF THE LAW ARE MORE IMPORTANT.
DAVE WANTS A DEBATE WITH
.
-- AOC.
SHE IS COY ABOUT THAT.
DAVE, ARE YOU COWERING?
>> NO, I WOULD LOVE TO TALK TO
MERAND HAVE HER DEBAIT.
I DON'T THINK SHE WILL DO IT.
-- WE TRIED TO RAISE DONATIONS.
SHE SENT OUT A LETTER.
I DOUBT SHE WILL STEP TO THE
PODIUM.
>> I SAW A FASCINATING
DISCUSSION ON FOX BUSINESS ABOUT
AN HOUR AGO WHO THINK THAT YOU
WERE SCREWED.
YOU ARE GOING DOWN.
YOU ARE FINISHED.
BUT SOME NATIONAL LABOR REVIEW
BOARD, TRUMPS THIS FIRST
AMENDMENT THING WITH SO-CALLED
FREEDOM OF SPEECH.
STEVE FORBES A FORMER
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE THINKS
YOU SHOULD BE QUAKING IN YOUR
SHOES.
>> I SAW THE DEBATE.
THE PEOPLE THAT THINK I AM GOING
TO JAIL, THEY ARE IDIOTS.
WE ARE A COMEDY CITE.
WE HAVE NO UNION AT BAR STOOL
SPORTS.
THE WHOLE UNION DEBATE, IT'S
JUST A CITE THAT I DON'T LIKE.
-- SITE.
I WAS MAKING FUN OF THEM.
I WASN'T TALKING ABOUT
FACTORIES.
I AM TALKING ABOUT BAR STOOL
SPORTS AND MAKING FUN OF OUR OWN
EMPLOYS.
IF YOU MAKE A UNION I WILL CRUSH
YOU AND THESE MORONS WHO HAVE NO
IDEA WHAT WE DO JUMP INTO THE
FRAY.
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ.
O-CRAZY-IO.
I KNOW DONALD WILL USE.
IT I WILL GET CREDIT FOR THAT.
THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
THEY JUMP INTO THE MUD.
GUESS WHAT?
WE THE BIGGEST DAY WE EVER HAD
AT BAR STOOL SPORTS.
THIS WAS A GUY WHO GOT DRAGGED
OUT OF THE SUPER BOWL IN
HANDCUFFS.
THESE PEOPLE SHOULD SPEND LESS
TIME TWEETING AND MORE TIME
WORKING.
THEN THEY DON'T HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT THE UNION.
>> AOC WHO IS ONLY RAISE $1525
FROM HER OWN CONSTITUENTS WITH A
SINGLE TWEET MADE MORE MONEY FOR
YOU?
>> YES.
AGAIN I DON'T THINK SHE HAS ANY
CLUE OF WHAT WE DO.
SHE JUMPED IN THE FRAY LIKE AN
IDIOT.
IF I HAD A NICKEL FOR EVERY TIME
THEY SAY I WILL SERVE A LIFE
LICENSE.